[Applause]
i'm enjoying my [__] life
that's all i'm saying i advise you to do
the same
do [__] that make you happy go out and
get you some white friends
get you some white [__] friends
you ain't gotta sleep with them but you
gonna need them [__]
if you go to jail and call your [__]
friends these [__] will
interrogate you more
than the goddamn police dig it they had
your ass on the phone where the [__] was
you
at what the [__] was you doing
why the [__] you ain't calling me not
your white friends that [__]
will be there by the time you hang up
the phone and they'll be madder than you
just what the [__] did he do
murder murdered who look i [__] known
it for two weeks he wouldn't [__] do
something like that gotta love white
people i don't give a [__] what you say
white people are friendly
you can call them [__] up at 3
o'clock in the morning with the wrong
number and they won't even be mad at you
hello no i'm sorry no shaquita here
well what number did you dial no it's a
nine not a seven
we'll try it if it doesn't work call me
back we'll figure this thing out
[Applause]
gotta love white people it's thanks to
white people we know anything about wild
animals you realize that [__] have
never in the history of niggerdom
discovered a wild animal not
one not a wild pit bull nothing cuz we
too cautious [__] don't
discover [__] we don't get close enough
to discover [__] take no chances that
what [__] is that a rottweiler or a
bear [__] go
go no go [__] that goat
white people though let me say this
y'all need some [__] friends get you
some [__] friends just don't ever ever
call them your [__] friends don't ever
that'll [__] the relationship up there's
my [__] friend
you guys say it all the time
[Music]
white people you need your [__] friends
so they can tell you when [__] is not
appropriate
first of all white people please stop
putting them little blue leashes on your
children please
stop doing that that is only
entertainment for [__] that's all that
is
we'd be excited then the [__]
look at him
that's why white kids grow up and kill
everybody in the goddamn school because
you don't treat
them like a german shepherd ever since
they were three they've been in the
store
uh uh chuck pruitt uh from lancaster
ohio do you have a black friend
does chuck pruitt have a black friend
mostly yeses but said fairly softly okay
does chuck have
a black friend a black friend yeah
name this person uh black friend uh
let's see who would that be i see
uh i think we're gonna call that or no
by the way he's still standing out there
trying to come up with a name
i am from the south i am from the south
and uh being from the south uh
i have a lot of white friends back home
and uh i'm their one
black friend yeah i'm their draft pick
[Music]
first round you know when that happens
when you're the one black friend you
become
the ambassador for all things black
anything's swirling around in their mind
they're like send it on hi to jordan
let him consult with the negro council
have him bring word back down the
mountain
and we shall ruminate upon it here in
caucasia
buddy of mine his name is stephen he
texts me other day he goes uh
race question here yeah
that's how he opened it you know like it
was jeopardy just
i'll take race for 400 alex
he goes a race question here do black
people get
ticks
[Laughter]
so lexi says someone at work told her
that black people don't get ticks
because of the type of shampoo that they
use
i was like nah bruh black people don't
get ticks because we stay the [__] up
out the wilderness like there's no
mystery to this [__] like what kind of
question is that
i vote that for every dumb question a
white person asks a black person we get
to delete one episode of friends from
history
right that's a fair trade right anytime
you're just like what's your hair feel
like it's like
i don't know if you're gonna figure out
if rachel got off that plane dog i'm
sorry i gotta
got one more time to sing smelly cat
[__]
[Applause]
i feel like i honestly feel like an
outsider in my friends groups a lot of
times because i am the one black friend
they've done a lot of things that i
haven't done you know they travel the
world they've had children
they've done drugs i've never done drugs
i've never done in my life i had a
roommate who was gay
i'm assuming he's still gay uh but he uh
he found out i had never done drugs he
tried to get me to do him he's like you
should try some drugs man i was like no
that's not really my thing he's like try
some drugs
like i'm not into that he goes you
should try cocaine
[Laughter]
i don't think you heard me i said i've
never done drugs
you don't tell somebody that doesn't
have a driver's license to try drag
racing
you know he started hitting all this
logic dude little cocaine a little bump
on the weekend a little too too cocaine
i was like man i never done cocaine he
goes cocaine don't even do anything
[Laughter]
he said cocaine just make you feel like
beyonce
it's like you're a horrible [__]
salesman it's like i'm a straight man i
don't want to feel like beyonce
that maybe your idol is not mine i hit
him back i was like you should try
[__] he was like i've never had [__]
before in my life i was like
man [__] don't even do anything
[__] just make you feel like dwayne the
rock johnson
do you smell what i'm cooking
actually i got a couple of friends of uh
african persuasion
and uh i gotta get rid of them man i
gotta admit to you
i'm finding i'm spending too much money
on clothes hanging out with them
because i gotta like [__] try to keep
up with their wardrobe
it's like every time they go out they
got all brand new [__] on
all brand new [__] so when i show up
with my white version of brand new which
is
you know i basically i ironed the [__]
right i ironed it right it's new
they just start trashing me i can't keep
up with them man they got like [__]
58 pairs of sneakers
ever notice that [__] like every color
[__] timberland
i don't give a [__] what [__] up color
their shirt is they got a pair of shoes
to match it and a hat
it's like a rule or something
they're the worst even when you wear
some new [__] there's like some sort of
rule
that you gotta like space out the amount
of time within which like that you wear
it
because god forbid you wear the same
shirt within a 10-day period one of
them's gonna notice
the old son just look at you funny like
this motherfucker's got the same [__]
he had on last tuesday and then the
whole car's like oh [__]
everybody just starts making fun of you
[__] close
first they do the math like what was
that five days ago five days this
[__] got five shirts
we got five shirts
they start breaking it down yo his first
shirt he's saying monday next [__] he's
saying tuesday
during the weekend he ain't wearing no
shirt
i'll tell you that's actually funny you
know what that's actually how i judge
black guys now
when i first came to the city like all
black people scared me
i was like the typical white dude from
like the suburbs you know what i mean
had no frame of reference you know
it's my only frame of reference with
black people like those remember those
early 90s gangster rap videos
throw the [__] la riots in there man
it was [__] horrible pr
i'm watching the videos so he's got a
nice car he's got all the women and he's
still [__] mad
these black dudes are never happy
but after 10 years of living in the sea
this is how i narrow it down
whether black dude scares me now black
dudes with dirty sneakers scare the
[__] [__] out of me
no i figured out my head because i know
from hanging out with them
that's the last [__] that they're gonna
let go the immediate [__] that they have
on so i think you know
if his sneakers are [__] up that means
his life is [__] up
every time he leaves his building the
whole neighborhood oh [__]
everyone sucks making fun of him
he's on the train in a bad mood i kind
of have this howdy duty kind of mug me
kind of face
i'm not saying something's gonna happen
i'm just saying i'm paying attention
but i didn't always know that was a
black thing it took me a while to
figure that out i learned i learned that
[__] in new york
i was in new york city
now i was hanging out with a friend of
mine he's a white guy you know we were
just hanging out
and we were lost in the city you know he
was smoking a joint now i don't know it
was a coincidence that we were
lost and high and [__] but
my white buddy he was smoking a joint
dave dave it's the goddamn cops
i'm going to ask him for directions
i said chip no chip don't do it
it was too late he was walking over
there this man was high as [__]
excuse me excuse me sir
touching him and [__] excuse me
you need some information uh start
confessing things you shouldn't confess
i'm a little high
all i want to know which way is third
street the cop was like hey
take it easy
you're on third street
you better be careful go ahead move it
move it
that's all that happened at the end of
the story
now i know that's not amazing of some of
you
but she has one of these black fellas
that [__] is [__] incredible isn't it
i'm saying a black man would never dream
of talking to the police high
that's a waste of weed
serious
i mean i'll be scared to talk to the
police when i'm sleepy
[__] around get the wrong ideas
oh my god that [__] was on pcp johnson
i had to use necessary force you saw him
no no no paperwork just just sprinkle
some crack on him let's get out of here